[Music]  our dignity our character our writings  have all been under attack stars all  over the country took to the streets  Saturday for the women's March 2017 just  one day after Donald Trump was sworn in  as the 45th President of the United  States America Ferrera Scarlett  Johansson's and daya Coleman and Chrissy  Teigen  were among the many celebs who marched  on in Washington DC  and Alicia Keys belted out her fitting  anthem girl on fire Chelsea Handler Mary  McCormack and Charlize Theron marched in  Park City Utah while idina menzel took  to the streets of downtown LA with her  close friends and the legendary Yoko Ono  held signs that read women power in New  York City ariana grande marched  alongside her mother and grandmother  while Katy Perry declared she'd be  marching with her sister Angela  [Music]